back in 2019 some AI researchers and
mathematicians came up with an ambitious
challenge to create an AI that could win
a gold medal at the international
mathematics Olympiad it was an ambitious
challenge because winning a gold medal
at this event puts you on the world
stage as having one of the best
mathematical Minds previous winners of
the gold medal include Terence Tao and
Mariam mirzakani the researchers called
it the IMO Grand Challenge and for an AI
system to pass they proposed the
following rules each proof that the AI
producers must be checkable in 10
minutes which is approximately the
amount of time it takes a human judge to
judge a human solution the AI only has
as much time as a human competitor which
is four and a half hours for each set of
three problems and the AI must be open
source released publicly and
reproducible the AI cannot query the
inte internet as of recording this we
have met chat GPT and gpt4 was released
a couple of months ago I'm sure that
we'll be continually Amazed by what it's
able to do but no AI including Church
EBT has yet won or even competed in the
IMO competition bits are on literally
for if and when one might succeed gpt4
is paraded around as having already aced
many other exams including the SAT and
the biology Olympiad but it might never
Ace the IMO because the thing is that
Chan gbt is actually not very good at
math it's not good at counting or
keeping track of multiple operations
because after all it is a language model
that excels at predicting the next word
in a sentence math questions on the SAT
can be quite predictable and formulaic
and likely enough similar problems were
included in the training data set that
it was able to get by but the IMO
problems are different and they're
designed to test true understanding and
creative problem solving I'd like to
understand the likelihood of an AI
passing this challenge soon but in order
to do that I would first need to
understand the solution to an IMO
problem myself on human terms then I
would like to understand how chat GPT
goes about solving it and then see if
there are any better AI competitors out
there here's an IMO problem this is the
Olympics for math so these problems are
some of the hardest out there and can
require Creative Solutions this is
problem six from the 2022 competition
let N be a positive integer a Nordic
square is an N times n board containing
all the integers from 1 to n squared so
that each cell contains exactly one
number
two different cells are considered
adjacent if they share a common side
every cell that is adjacent only to
cells containing larger numbers is
called a valley an uphill path is a
sequence of one or more cells such that
the first cell in the sequence is a
valley each subsequent cell in the
sequence is adjacent to the previous
cell and the numbers written in the
cells in the sequence are an increasing
order find as a function of n the
smallest possible number of uphill paths
in a Nordic Square this is an example of
a Nordic Square where n is equal to two
here one is our Valley and we could have
six possible uphill paths one to two
then one to two to four which is counted
as a different uphill path you could do
one to three or one to three to four and
we also have to include the path of
length one which is just the valley we
could have placed these numbers in the
squares in any the order it didn't have
to be in this pattern it could have gone
one two three four and in fact you
should play around with it now trying
Nordic squares of different sizes and
different Arrangements of the numbers to
see what kinds of patterns might give
you this smallest number of total uphill
paths if you want to try it for yourself
now is your time to pause I don't think
it's possible for a human to look at
this and know the solution instantly you
really do have to play around and try a
bunch of random things to see if any
patterns pop out here's an example of a
three by three Nordic Square which looks
like it might have the minimum paths for
the size again we only have one Valley
and it is our one but we could also have
one two one two six one two seven one
three one three eight one three seven
one five one five nine
one five six
one four one four eight one four nine
giving a total of Thirteen Parts you can
easily find other three by three
Arrangements that have more parts than
this and the Crux of the solution comes
down from recognizing two things one is
that for the minimum number of Parts you
want there to be only one Valley like we
have here our number one and you also
need to recognize that for every pair of
adjacent numbers there needs to be only
one path back to the valley
say here two and six are adjacent
numbers and from them there was only one
path back down to our Valley which was
like this this essentially means you can
have two paths coming to a common
endpoint but you can never have this
two paths converging and then continuing
on because that would mean that from
wherever this ends these two adjacent
numbers will have multiple paths back
down to the valley so this is not
allowed and we can call something like
this our end point a sink with this
we've given ourselves the golden ticket
if every two adjacent numbers only have
one path back to the belly then the
minimum number of paths in our Nordic
Square would be equal to the number of
adjacent numbers counting the pairs of
adjacent numbers here we have one two in
each row and there's three rows so that
would be
two times three that's six adjacent
numbers that are adjacent horizontally
Plus
one two three four five six going
vertically so there'd be 12 pairs of
adjacent numbers that's our number of
minimum paths but we have to remember to
add one because our Valley our single
Valley will also be its own single
length path giving 13 as the total
minimum paths in this case to extend
that for any number of n we will always
have n minus 1 adjacent numbers on each
row times n rows and N minus 1 adjacent
numbers on each column times the number
of columns so that's
2 N times n minus 1 paths Plus
one to account for our Valley that's
basically the answer here and that will
give you some points but more points
will come from new harder task of
describing how to arrange the numbers to
get this minimum and that part of the
solution comes from describing a
tree-like structure like this if you put
the numbers in increasing order in these
trees you end up with only one Valley
and for every adjacent pair of numbers
only one path back to it the black
numbers here represent numbers higher
than 153 so you fill in all these ones
first and then go back and fill in the
black spaces with the higher ones these
black numbers are sinks and there might
be multiple ways to end at the sink but
there'll never be a way out let's give
the problem to chat gbt and see what it
does the 2022 problem I picked wouldn't
be in the GPT training data set I'm
using the latest model gpt4 and it gives
me the wrong answer it says that the
smallest number of paths is equal to N I
asked it in how many values there should
be to minimize the number of paths and
it immediately gives a square with three
valleys it says that the minimum is n
values which gives in paths and if you
remember recognizing that there must
only be one Valley is key to getting the
solution
I asked it to make a Nordic square with
only one Valley which it did but then it
failed to count more than one path
and when I asked it to do it for larger
squares it gave constructions that for
each adjacent pair there were multiple
paths back to the valley and it just
couldn't count paths correctly even when
I tried to point out mistakes I don't
think it would be able to score any
points on this question at the moment
this recent paper from Microsoft
analyzed the abilities of gpt4 and said
there were Sparks of artificial general
intelligence which refers to AI that is
broadly intelligent at or above human
level and not just good at one specific
task they mentioned that chat gbt is
trained on a massive amount of webtext
data and users at its core a
self-supervised objective of predicting
the next word in a partial sentence the
paper also shows that gpt4 does not have
the capacity required to conduct
mathematical research it does manage to
solve one IMO question in here but in
any other problems it lacks critical
reasoning and the ability to examine
each step of its arguments they say one
reason for this might be that in most of
the math Solutions it's read on the
internet most just give the correct
answer but don't capture the thinking
process it doesn't make guesses or
backtrack because it can't backtrack
when predicting the next word it just
needs to move forward in a straight line
in essence it's bad at math because it
lacks the ability to play around
so chat gbt fails for now but it's not
the only competitor the people at open
AI in fact some of the same people who
came up with the IMO Grand Challenge in
the first place work on a different AI
system one that according to this paper
published in 2022 has already managed to
solve some IMO problems it's not a
language model but instead is a
proof-solving model that speaks the
language of formal math automated proof
solvers have existed for a little while
but this one is trained to iteratively
search for new proofs it takes
mathematical ideas that need to be
proved and breaks them down into smaller
and smaller statements that are easier
to prove until there's nothing left to
prove this is what the formal math
language looks like it's not too easy
for a human to read but it's probably
our best bet when creating a system that
is actually useful to mathematicians it
uses something called the lean theorem
proofer the proofs that it creates are
machine checkable following a series of
logical laws they say that their model
and search procedure are capable of
producing proofs that chain multiple
non-trivial reasoning steps and it does
require some creativity to invent lines
like this combining an AI that can speak
formal math and correctly prove
statements with something like chat GPT
to make it more user-friendly could
really make some waves in math and much
more likely to pass the IMO Grand
Challenge than a language model alone
and as I mentioned while chat gbt is
still struggling with IMO problems it
has already passed a bunch of exams
there's a note here back in the
Microsoft paper saying that gpd4 does
not rely on memorizing the exact problem
statement but on applying a general
solution method while it is possible
that gpt4 memorizes the solution
template this is not necessarily a flaw
as it is also a common way of solving
math problems for humans they're saying
that gpt4 has been able to pass a bunch
of exams by doing what many of us do
which is kind of memorizing the
structure of common problems looking
through past papers and solutions can
often give you enough of what you need
to do well in an exam because the
structures are usually pretty much the
same and if this is what chat gbt is so
good at too then perhaps this is the
space in which exams will change a bit
perhaps for now exams will have to
change to be a little bit more like the
IMO to reward creative problem solving
and necessitate having to stop and play
around with the problem that seems like
it is still a uniquely human trait but
I'm not sure for how long that will be
the case thanks for watching this video
and thanks to my patreon supporters for
making it possible a special shout out
to today's patreon cat of the day
Cthulhu
foreign
[Music]